You are listening to radiolab radio from W.
N y. S. E. N. N. P. R.
Okay. So you know, uh, the [inaudible] core of our job right,
is to ask people questions, right? Yes.
Then we sit there for hours and edit the answers. And I've noticed that, um,
the answers sometimes have a kind of musicality to them.
Like sometimes you get this. That's right. No, right? Yes,
no way. Right, right, right. Yes. Oh No,
I didn't know that. Those are the shot quick Staccato beats. Yes. Yes.
This is like the sound of certainty, right?
But there are times when you get a completely different music, you know,
like say you're asking a hard question or a clarifying question,
is it a or is it B? Then sometimes you get this,
well, it certainly, let me just see. He,
his, um, um, I mean, yeah, well,
but I think
you get this kind of melodic wavering. No, I, it's, I,
I,
you know, in purely musical terms,
the pitches and the first one are like pow, POW, pow.
They're just precise and quick.
But in that second category that pictures are floating up or floating down,
they're never stable. You're not normal person. Really know what it's like.
That's the sound of doubt. Doubt.
[inaudible]
you know, we could do, what's that? We have collected some stories,
which in a way they all have doubt in them that you have certainty in them and
what they all are are, are kind of collisions. Really.
We have three stories for you. Difficult, complex,
emotionally wrenching situations,
kind of situations you can't really walk away from and you can't resolve them.
So you have to do something. And that's this show that's going to be our show.
We should call it. Um, are you sure? No, no. H I don't know yet.
I have to think about, that's what I'm suggesting as the name. Are you sure?
Are you sure? Yes. Are you sure? He said,
listen,
I'm Jad Abumrad he's driving crullers his radio lab and to get something
started. Are you sure? That's good.
We start with a producer we've worked with for a very long time. Lulu Miller.
Very interesting story, which takes many twists and turns.
It begins actually with the fact that as a girl,
Lulu really loved rocks. She just loved to sit on rock.
She loved to think about rocks. She just liked rocks.
They felt slightly animate in the way that a tree does or that an animal does
that. I know it's not a human, um,
but it's a nice thing in the world that for whatever reason brings about a
feeling of peace. Then one day, seventh grade, Mr Pricer, you science teacher,
he did a lesson on inorganic versus organic matter and we make this huge list on
the chalkboard organic matter trees. Yup. Thugs. Yup.
Pasta shirt.
It's kind of blowing our minds because it seems like everything's organic.
A corpse was organic.
Even a table is organic because wood used to be alive and then he had draws this
like harsh white lined on the chalkboard and he writes in organic metal salt
rocks and I was like, oh
no. I mean it sounds a little bit silly,
but this was actually a big deal for Lulu and she, even when she worked with us,
she would talk about this. But then you fast forward many years.
Actually when she was leaving the show,
she decided to bike across the country from California to New York and she meets
somebody who changes things for her and her rocks
and pretty much everything. Well,
I met him in the middle of possibly the loneliest place in the world.
It's called the loneliest road in America highway route 50.
And it's just a two lane road that crosses the state of Nevada desert desert
desert. This is the sound of a busted bike,
broke ins book, a rip tire,
just desert stretches for a hundred miles at a time. Oh,
did you end up having to ride a hundred miles in one day down? Oh yeah.
Okay. So you're in the middle of this, uh, this expanse of dread.
Yes. And what happens
finally, make it late in the afternoon to basically our end point for the day.
Little gas station with a little diner and we see out in front of the restaurant
this bike that's like loaded down with so much gear and you're like,
oh, fellow traveler. Yup. So we went in, picked him out immediately.
She was the only other person in this kind of like biker bar,
basically wearing Lycra. He's young. He was early twenties,
big red beard. This young dude from Kentucky with a little drawl.
His name is Jeff, Jeff, Jeff Vineyard. So his story was that he,
um, he was about to be getting married and he was supposed to be doing this trip
with his fiance, Megan,
but at sort of at the last minute just due to wedding planning,
logistics and all that. She had decided not to come on the trip, but you know,
so he's doing it alone and just kind of thinking of it as a little bit of
reflection time before he gets married. Um,
he had just finished Grad school in geosciences,
so geology and like tracking earth statistical data you have in the same
direction that you guys were going.
He was going our way to [inaudible] and he said, you know,
oh look mind if I ride with you to the campsite. And we said sure.
And then we ended up
riding together for about 11 days. So you get to know him,
really got to know him. This is us,
Nevada, well, hymns, you know, uh,
well that was a dod of amazing grains. Yeah. And that's him singing,
uh, by or fear.
The other little part to tell you beforehand is just that Jeff grew up very
religious. GRANDPA was a preacher and his fiance,
Megan, also very devout, very religious, has always felt the presence of God.
Yeah. Uh, [inaudible]
did he actually met Megan through his church?
They met while doing mission work down in Louisiana.
Can we go look at a rock really quick? Okay. So we meet this dude.
He's a geologist.
He sings all the time and about three or four days into riding together,
he says something that completely changes my understanding of the world.
Any clue what that is?
No. Can I get some water and rinse them off? Yep.
Yeah. Okay.
We are pulled over to the side of the road in Utah and Jeff has us looking at
some rock washing it off this,
this might be a limestone.
And then he just starts casually mentioning how limestone is formed.
So it's a sedimentary rock and it forms from what used to be the bottom of sea
force. What actually causes it to form, um,
is there is plankton in the water and um,
lots of these small organisms that have very, very, very small shells,
you know, microscopic. Um,
all that's left of these organisms after they die or they're small shells get
deposited on the sea floor and then more shells get deposited over top of them.
And then over the course of many, many years, you have these very,
very thick, almost like drifts of, um,
of these plankton shells. And then, you know,
there's tremendous pressure at the bottom of the sea floor and they compress and
they compress and they solidify and they turn into limestone.
You're saying that these rocks are made out of thousands and thousands of little
critters. Critters pretty much thought a rock couldn't have been a lie.
That's saying that, that that rock is composed of something,
many thousands of things that were once alive. Yeah.
I don't know whether I would necessarily call the show part of the live,
but it doesn't matter. I'd heard what I needed to hear.
They do have a little bit of life inside them in a very real tangible,
see-able way. Like not a poetic idea. They do. Yeah they do.
They do.
I mean it was there at one point.
I'm sure I must have in some other way learn this.
I mean this is basic rock knowledge, but I somehow missed it.
You sound very excited. Yes,
he gives me my friends back like with a scientist wand. All right. But, but,
but yes, this is not actually the story I want to tell you.
I'm not, I'm sorry it took me a little long to get here.
But the real story I wanna tell you is about a very similar thing happening only
with much bigger consequences
cause we kept on riding in the Utah Hills.
We make it through one of the hardest days of biking ever.
And we finally make it to Cedar City, Utah. And we decided to go out for it.
Pizza to celebrate. We're taking a first bite. And then Jeff,
who's usually so just like polite and sweet,
he slammed down his root beer and he says,
I was supposed to be getting married today. Whoa. What does that mean?
Well, that's what we thought. We were like, what?
Finally he told us this whole story that actually a couple months before the
bike trip, one Tuesday they were making dinner together.
We were at her house and we were cooking and you basically suddenly felt this
feeling inside his chest like right behind my sternum. I just thought,
shit, I don't believe in God anymore.
Really? Yeah. Yeah.
This just landed on him out of the blue. Completely without warning. Wait,
where? Where, where? What was it? When did it feel like?
I don't know. I don't even know if it was like words, but it was just,
I believe in God.
Were you then terrified? Yeah. Who wouldn't be?
He believed in God his entire life. Yeah.
And now gone just like that.
Was he thinking about something or, I don't know.
I kept asking him and that was the best he could say.
And Megan saw the look on his face and asked him what was wrong.
I didn't say anything at the time, I'm just like, just have indigestion. Um,
you know, but a few weeks later I filled her in on the, and that was probably,
you know, Megan's a person,
deep belief and that was something she wanted her husband to be at least
somewhat on board with. So they put the wedding on hold,
postponed it in good faith that we will work things out. So in a way,
what he was doing on the bike trip was literally like scanning the hillsides to
find some evidence of God to win back his bread. Oh,
so this wasn't like a pre wedding reflective ride thing at all? No Way.
And you're saying he wanted evidence? Yes.
Evidence or proof.
I wanted it to be on one side of the fence or the other is one demand for God
was a few exists and you're at all interested in people.
Show yourself there is no reason you shouldn't.
So that whole time when I was riding along thinking gay,
my rock buddies are back.
Jeff was waiting for some signal from the landscape.
Now there is a time where I'm climbing up this mountain when it comes up behind
me and like I'm thinking, wow, this is great. It feels like I'm being pushed.
Yeah. Is this just the wind or is this something else? I don't know.
And for the three weeks he'd been riding, nothing had really convinced him? No,
no. He was just frustrated, despondent,
angry in six days after what was supposed to be Jeff's wedding day, June 4th,
we, um,
part ways.
And then I had no idea what became of him. Huh?
I didn't hear anything from him for almost a year.
And then I guess he had my phone number from just, you know,
we'd had each other's phones while we were traveling together and he called and
said that he was on a little road trip and he's going to be passing through
Charlottesville and could he stay with me for a night?
Hello? Hello, hello.
And I said, sure, do you want to set that? You want to set the scene for us?
And basically this second he arrives, I asked him, okay,
so what happened in your gray hair? Have you found God, are you with Megan?
And I wonder if like
where are you at with all that? Oh,
you know, like that's right there. Um,
he told me that toward the end of his ride he started to get really anxious.
Okay. Trips almost over. Got like a week.
And are you thinking like
lightning bolts? Show me a, an angel, what are you, what are you hoping to see?
Anything.
And then he tells me there was a point outside of Hazard Kentucky or just
feeling really low.
And then I was eating lunch at Arby's and I know this is where the story gets
embarrassing. Um, a ceiling tile fell on my sandwich. Okay. Yeah.
And I'm like a plaster ceiling. Yeah. Like one of the drop ceiling tiles.
Just splat. Wow. Yeah. And so,
and then what happened is a guy sitting over at the next table noticed him,
walks over and gives me a sandwich when we got to talking. And of course, like,
you know, he's a minister and,
and Jeff just starts telling him everything that's going on.
He's having trouble with his face and how he's not sure what's going to happen
with Megan.
So we talked about that for a while and at the end of the conversation the man
gives Jeff a blessing like append addiction, have a good journey,
be safe. And I hate to recount it because it just sounds so a ceiling tile fell.
The guy came over and talked to me like, is that really remarkable?
But in that dark place I feel like maybe it was
[inaudible]
I don't know. And I'm confused.
And when he finally made it home to Megan, that's what he told her.
I don't know. Yeah,
we both just kind of sat there for a long time cause we didn't really know what
to do with that.
But I knew in my heart that I wanted to marry someone who shared my faith and
just kept hoping that he would find his faith again.
And this was just a phase or something and it was much bigger than that.
And eventually I figured out what I wanted to do and cried a lot. And
then
I went and talked to him at his house.
She just sat him down and gave him his ring back.
It was really sad. Neither of us wanted that to happen.
We
cried together a little bit and then I think he needed me to just leave.
Yeah.
It was definitely hard to walk out of that room.
It didn't work out. So I'm up in Columbus,
I'm staying in Columbus. Um, because I like it there. Um,
I know you moved up to Columbus to be with her, right? Yeah.
So he got a job turning riches of the bicycle shop. Yeah.
It's a long way from Geo statistics.
Yeah. Rocks.
I'm sorry, I didn't realize.
No, don't be, um, I'm gonna try. Okay. Yeah.
I turned off the tape recorder and took him out to a really good bar again.
He's headed back to Columbus and you know, just down
and that's it. That was just, it. That was kind of their ending and I, you know,
I figured that's end of story. And then,
yeah, another year goes by. And luckily we moved slowly on,
taped on stories and a strange invitation appears in my mailbox.
I open it up and it's an invitation to Jeff Vineyard and Megan Swain.
These wedding really wait, a year goes by,
you just suddenly get a thing to their wedding. What happened? Um,
all right. Shall we commence Lulu? We shall commence.
Well I didn't know what happened. Megan
is walking up right now actually. Hi. All right,
well first of all, I like what happened cause I've, I know nothing. Um,
well let's
have him tell that story and then we'll go from there.
Um,
I had reached a point where I was actually back in attending church.
I had found a really friendly congregation here in town.
Um,
I was just looking for something familiar because I moved up here and the one
person I know is not in my life and I need something else.
So I wasn't necessarily going for the preaching.
I was just going for the experience in,
for kind of the pure on the bum and the people around, you know. Right.
I mean I was, I was singing with our church choir at that point because,
you know, I wasn't really sure whether I had any faith or not,
but gosh darn are now like singing.
And then he told me one day
just some, Gosh darn Sunday, I don't know what we were singing.
I don't know what the sermon was about. Um,
but we were taking communion as I was taking the elements.
I just said he just suddenly felt like
the air charge,
like there is a palpable presence all around,
just, just almost like a tempest.
I felt there was something there. Was it something you felt up in your head?
Was it something you felt sternum mostly beneath the sternum.
Huh? The tightness a hand, something touching there. Huh.
Very strange. I don't know what to make it that still. Um,
I'm still not sure if it was something defined,
another worldly or if it was just a profound appreciation for the history of
that gesture. Um,
had almost just wanna say like Jeff Right now.
Do you believe in God? Yeah.
It's just really different from what I felt earlier
and it's still very uncertain.
Megan, when when you hear him talk about doubt, is it scary?
Is it something you can relate to? I mean how,
like how does it strike you when he talks about it?
It is a little scary cause I think it's still a hard thing for us.
Keep in mind, I'm talking to them 10 days before they're about to get married.
Is it 10 or 11 I think it's 10 yeah,
10 some days.
Sometimes it seems like we're really close on how we believe and sometimes it
seems like we're miles apart.
It's confusing sometimes but that's, I don't know. I'm okay with that.
And Megan are, are you okay with that? I am.
I don't know if it's just me still wishing a little,
but his faith is a little more like mine. Maybe.
I haven't completely let go of that. But on
a day to day basis,
we pray together in the evenings and are able to talk about religious things
without fighting with each other.
And I think that whatever differences we do have are okay.
Now
love is a choice.
I think after a certain point we just chose that we were going to love each
other anyway.
[inaudible] they go forward and they get married. Yeah,
it was a religious ceremony. And
do they say their vow?
[inaudible] thank you Megan. Be My one promise before God,
before God and all who are present here
and what was just like, as he's saying his vows, you can hear
[inaudible]
biggest sob I've ever heard just like comes out of his voice like that.
It, it just felt like bigger than him.
[inaudible]
Jeff said later that what that was was not the sound of resolution
but of relief worth long as we go. [inaudible]
perfect.
It is my great pleasure to introduce to you,
Mr and Mrs Jeffrey and Megan Vineyard.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
big thanks to producer Lou Miller. We'll continue in a moment.